hey youtubers is Charlie and my Game of
Thrones Season 4 countdown continues for
this video I thought it'd be fun to do a
history of dragons in the world a lot of
dragons history gets tied up with the
Targaryen so whenever they get into
Westeros so for this video let's try and
focus on flame and scale as much as
possible if you're finding me for the
first time I'm just doing a fun
countdown to the season 4 premiere with
bonus videos be sure to subscribe to get
everything if there's any videos that
you see that I haven't done please feel
free to suggest one in the comments so
at the start of book 1 and season 1
dragons have been believed extinct for
over 150 years
the last living dragon died during the
reign of Aegon the third nicknamed the
dragon Bane at the point in where we are
currently in the chronology of Ice and
Fire
there are several historical texts about
dragon lore so if someone in the series
like Samwell wanted to learn more
he'd have to learn from either someone
like old amon at the Nights Watch or
from one of the other rare existing
texts one of the things I really love
about George are Martin is is that he
includes super fine details like this
hopefully someone will actually write
these books in real life someday so that
we can actually read them here they are
in no particular order number one blood
and Fire also known as the death of the
Dragons it's one of the rare texts about
dragons in King's Landing it's supposed
to be hidden somewhere underneath the
maester Citadel and Old Town for some
reason it's covered in blood they're not
really clear on whether that's dragon's
blood or human blood number two Dragons
worms and wyverns they're a natural
history written by Septon Barth he was
actually the hand of the king during the
reign of Jairus the first the other
septons considered barque to be
something of a sorcerer so later during
the reign of Baylor the first who was
also a Septon all the copies of this
book were actually burnt but a few pages
are supposed to have survived till today
and Tyrion even had one at one point
it's really notable for claiming that
dragons are neither male nor female they
can switch gender at will meaning that
Daenerys dragons will be able to
reproduce with each other at some point
number three the dance of the Dragons a
true telling' by grand maester Monken
it's a fictional text of the Targaryen
Civil War Dance of the dragons in real
life though George R Martin published a
pretty inclusive retelling of the dance
of the Dragons called the princess and
the Queen which you can actually read as
part of the dangerous women and the
number four dragonkin by meister tomax
it's actually a book that exists at
Castle black at the Nights Watch the
copy belonged to maester aemon until he
died when Jon Snow took it if you
remember in the trailer you can actually
see Samwell and Jon poring over text in
the Nights Watch library maybe at some
point during the season they'll actually
find that book careful for spoilers for
this next book because it includes some
things from Dance with Dragons so if you
don't know anything just skip forward in
the video about 30 seconds or so in the
last book number 5 the shy maids dragon
lore is actually a book being planned by
Tyrion but because he needs to do more
research he's hoping to get another
famous book the fires of the freehold a
concise history of old Valyria which
actually has details about ancient
dragons so that's the end of the spoiler
part but talking about oval area is a
good way to transition to the beginning
of dragons coexisting with humans
very little is actually known about the
lineage of the great dragons before the
Targaryens brought them to Westeros but
there are some cool facts about how they
were used in Valyria as a source of
influence and power
so the Valerians actually started out as
sheep herders in the east in about 5,000
years before the current events they
found dragons roosting in the 14 fires
all ring of volcanoes around the
peninsula where they lived they
eventually learned to tame them and with
the traditional use of domestication and
magic they use the dragons to carve out
what would become the great Valyrian
empire that existed until the doom their
territory basically ran along the entire
eastern continent and they were ruled by
a group of people not just one king and
queen the most powerful of them the most
powerful families were called the
Dragonlords
so quick sidenote about the actual magic
the Valerians use because it's a little
bit different from the other types of
magic in the world the type of magic
that they use was specifically tied to
dragons called blood and flame but the
other kinds you can find in the world
include elemental control divination
skin changing raising the dead
necromancy and glamouring so now we have
to talk about the Targaryens just a
little bit because their history is tied
up with dragons so much but in old
Valyria of the 40 families comprising
the Dragonlords they were actually a
pretty minor house so they were not a
big deal at all but they were the only
family that survived the doom so
whenever they brought dragons to
Westeros they were able to rule
challenged to become this big massive
family we do know the names of most of
the dragons starting at this point
though when Aegon brought the three
first dragons to Westeros including his
dragon balerion Rainey's dragon mer AXYZ
and Visenya as dragon veigar valerian is
the most famous just because of his size
he's like a house you can actually see
how Daenerys kind of mirrors Aegon and
that she brought three dragons into the
world
drogon being the closest analog of
balerion he ended up living for about
two hundred years and just died of old
age unlike all the other dragons during
the Civil War if you ever wondered why
Harrenhal looks so melty and ominous
it's because Aegon used balerion and the
other dragons to roast hair in the black
right after he finished the castle and
moved in he had boasted that it was
impregnable but turns out walls do not
keep dragons out another really cool
fact about balerion is is that whenever
he conquered the six kingdoms remember
he's in conquer Dorne and took their
swords to melt them down to make the
Iron Throne Valerians fire was used to
help smelt the metal after their death
the lineage of the Dragons gets a little
spotty but we do know about the six that
belonged to J Harris the first and then
the many that were part of the dance of
the dragons during that there were six
greens ten blacks to the chains from
blacks to greens remember dragons are
very changeable to neutral dragons and
then one that survived after that the
last living dragon existed during the
time of Aegon the third roughly about a
hundred and fifty years before events on
the show so obviously Daenerys could not
have brought dragons back into the world
if there were no dragon eggs
so whenever they're talking about
dragons not existing or you know going
extinct from the world they're just
talking about living breathing dragons
dragons lay a lot of eggs and not all of
them get hatched so if they go and hatch
the long enough they'll just become
petrified the ones that Dany was given
were petrified but the magic of Mirri
Maz Duur combined with Dany sacrificing
her on Khal Drogo's funeral pyre brought
them back in the book it said that
mirror used a blood magic spell and her
own sacrifice made it complete I choose
to believe that it was connected to the
same type of magic practiced by the
Valyrians so it's really interesting to
note that there is one other dragon egg
in present-day that's known to have
existed
supposedly euron greyjoy said that he
had an
but then threw it into the seed because
it was petrified and he didn't really
know about blood magic remember though
he is the one that has the Valyrian
dragon horn so hopefully some point in
the future he'll be able to use that so
if you want to learn more about dragons
in Game of Thrones I recommend you read
George RR Martin's short story the
princess in the Queen
it covers things in fascinating detail
but be sure to let me know what your
favorite dragon is in Game of Thrones it
doesn't have to be at alive when it
could be one that existed at any point
as cool as drogon is getting on the show
it would have been so much fun to fly on
balerion he is like as big as a house
it'd be like flying on a jumbo jet the
breeze flame so be sure to subscribe to
get the rest of my countdown videos and
remember to leave me suggestions for
future videos in the comments right now
click here to learn about winds of
winter there's actually a couple of
excerpts that have been published and
click here to get the rest of my season
4 breakdowns thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight for
Walking Dead high fives
you